[Music]
i fly
or i fall
yeah
who the hell are you
you won't remember me
but a long time ago you changed my life
when you left off another roof
back then i was just like any other cop
pretending my life
until i looked up and i saw
you
it was a different you but i saw
the real you
just a second before
you left
and you never fell
i knew one day i would find you
and that when i did you would be ready
for this
[Music]
if you want the truth neo
you're going to have to follow me
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating loops
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious
but this is the moment for you to show
us what is real
[Music]
i remember this
[Music]
so deja vu
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this is the story we think it is
they taught you
good made you believe their world was
all you deserved
but some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
it's so easy to forget how much noise
the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of
noise
war
the most important choice in neil's life
it's not his to me
she believed in me
it's my turn to believe in her
[Music]
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
if you want to see trinity again
i saw this in a dream
my dream ended here
[Music]
i still know kung fu
[Music]
you